cibo spreco zero
rivoluzione almeno forse per avere una
visione una visione sul sul futuro è
un'azione sul presente oggi cosa
possiamo fare
intanto partiamo dalle parole forse
abusate
ma ammettiamo l'insieme proviamo cibo
quattro lettere durante expo ne abbiamo
sentito parlare tanto forse non sappiamo
più cos'è se fate un elenco di aggettivi
che usiamo correntemente capite che il
cibo alto il cibo basso il cibo giusto
il cibo ingiusto il cibo sprecato il
cibo scialacquato il cibo il cibo
spadellato ne troviamo tantissimi e sono
tutti delle dicotomie delle
polarizzazioni tanto che non sappiamo
più se siamo bulimici anoressici se
siamo grassi se siamo magri spendiamo di
più per metterci a dieta che per
mangiare almeno nel nostro paese e siamo
disorientati e non sappiamo più che il
cibo serve per vivere è un bisogno
primario senza cibo non si non si vive e
nel cibo c'è l'acqua perché l'acqua che
usiamo per produrre il cibo gli alimenti
e nel mondo
l'ottanta per cento che viene utilizzata
quindi quando mangiamo in realtà non lo
sappiamo
vediamo come ci insegna il maestro altan
eppure in queste quattro lettere
noi dobbiamo ritrovare l'essenza la vera
essenza del cibo che viene anche
sprecato cibo spreco se ne spreca
tantissimo non ce ne rendiamo conto
perché noi non diamo forse più valore a
questo cibo tanto cibo ancora buono
finisce nel bidone della spazzatura
nelle nostre case in italia
se mettiamo assieme la filiera dal campo
alla forchetta dal campo alla tavola e
tutti i passaggi che sono che servono
per portare il cibo nelle nostre case
la produzione agricola la trasformazione
l'industrial distribuzione grande e
piccola e mercati all'ingrosso
fino alla ristorazione facciamo 150 si
perde per tante ragioni nelle fasi
commerciale il resto 50 metà a casa
nostra il cibo che finisce però nel
bidone della spazzatura ancora buona
questo è lo spreco ma lo definirà meglio
dopo e è qualcosa che non si può
recuperare diventa rifiuto e nel momento
in cui rifiutiamo qualcosa che ancora
buono qualcosa che ha un difetto
estetico che ha una scadenza ravvicinata
e perché abbiamo paura perché siamo
insicuri il passo poi per rifiutare
l'altro il diverso e nella nostra
società qui siamo è un attimo l'abbiamo
già fatto e pur lo spreco se ti poni
nell'ottica di poterlo recuperare o
addirittura meglio ancora di prevenire
di prevenirlo diventa un'occasione
diventa un'opportunità e strano questa
parola così negativa abusata forse come
il cibo la sentiamo ripetere ripetere
ripetere si spreca tutto il tempo la
vita il cibo naturalmente però proviamo
a vedere qual è l'opportunità dividiamo
line2 questa parola in due parti quasi
fosse una sillabazione una grammatica un
lessico che dobbiamo ricostruire forse
anche nella nostra testa
e c'è una parte negativa la prima spr ci
mettiamo un meno una piccola formula
semplice e la parte del del rifiuto
della spazzatura che dobbiamo ridurre in
effetti forse c'è troppa esse alla
montagna di spazzatura che ci circonda
aggiungiamo gli sprechi prodotti ha
ancora buoni che finiscono la spazzatura
beh poi non ne usciamo più
questo bisogna che lo riduciamo che
mettiamo un meno davanti ma poi c'è una
grande opportunità perché c'è la seconda
parte della della stessa parola
ecco è una radice è una casa qualcosa
che che si richiama che rimbalza ma ci
sono due
ecco in questa visione che vi voglio
proporre c'è un'eco piccola che è la
nostra casa
l'economia si
economia è una casa dentro c'è la nostra
vita c'è la famiglia c'è il cibo ci sono
le relazioni ci sono i nostri vestiti
c'è tutto quello che facciamo c'è un
tetto importante averla ma anche nel suo
significato di risparmiare fare economia
dobbiamo renderci conto che questa casa
sta dentro in una casa più grande e
l'ecologia è un'altra casa e la stessa
radice solo che è più grande perché
contiene deve contenere delle risorse
delle risorse naturali l'acqua l'energia
il suolo e cosa servono poi queste
risorse naturali limitate per produrre
il cibo se siamo in grado e lo siamo di
combinarle al meglio con la nostra
sapienza di agricoltori di contadini di
imprenditori agricoli che mettono
assieme le conoscenze per far arrivare
all'alimento dal campo quel campo alla
tavola eppure noi sappiamo dalla fisica
che le risorse naturali sono limitate si
rinnovano nel tempo forse dovremmo
lasciare il tempo a queste risorse di
rinnovarsi il suolo questa strato di 70
centimetri che la pelle della terra
l'acqua l'energia quella rinnovabile
e allora se la vediamo così la
casagrande
beh non ha senso pensare che la casa
piccola la casa domini sovrasti la
casagrande allora in questa visione di
spreco e di opportunità troviamo un
percorso vedere la casa piccola
all'interno dei limiti della casa più
grande e questo vuol dire rispettare i
limiti delle risorse naturali riguardare
il nostro modello di sviluppo che è
sempre in avanti però è lineare
questa crescita dove devi produrre
produrre produrre quindi consumare
consumare
consumare e dunque anche sprecare cos'è
la rottamazione esaurire un prodotto
prima che sia davvero finito allora in
questa visione di spreco divisa in due
parti dove eco e il futuro la
sostenibilità a durare nel tempo
rivediamo una sfida che è quella del
nostro tempo e non solo del futuro di
vedere l'economia circolare dove quello
che è rifiuto per di una di una risorsa
diventa bene per un'altra specie dove
gli animali e lo vediamo nell'economia
della natura non mangiano le risorse che
hanno a disposizione altrimenti non
sopravvivono dove non c'è disoccupazione
ma torniamo alla terza parola lo zero è
un obiettivo in realtà che numera al
minimo un obiettivo alto allora in
questa visione di di tre parole qual è
il nostro futuro riuscire a combinarle
cibo spreco zero
cos'è il cibo cos'è lo spreco cos'è lo
zero riusciamo a capire che il percorso
che abbiamo davanti ci porta a due
azioni fondamentali che sono quello di
recuperare tutto il cibo in eccesso in
surplus che non viene venduto e che non
si può e che non si può fare un'azione
preventiva e quindi la straordinarietà
del recupero attraverso il dono di chi
produce qualcosa di più non riesce a
venderlo non riesce a collocare sul
mercato e chi invece ha bisogno
e allora anche l'economia nella sua
circolarità riscopra unpli scopre un
valore che è di relazione nel momento in
cui mette a fattor comune mckee il
legame chi ha un eccedenze chi ha una
carenza chi può donare un prodotto
alimentare chi può riceverlo attivi
poiché non hai bisogno di prezzi non hai
bisogno del mercato una relazione è quel
bene che recuperi diventa relazionale e
questa la visione sul futuro immettere
nell'economia qualcosa che sembra
esterno ma che è sempre stato lì e
pensare che nei valori che siamo
abituati a utilizzare anche mentalmente
il valore di scambio il valore d'uso
scambio un prodotto lo uso mangio bevo
mi vesto c'è un valore di relazione che
avviene attraverso il dono ed è questo
il primo passo che dobbiamo fare pensare
che l'economia può essere diversa
circolare e anche gratuita di relazione
e allora lo spreco diventa
un'opportunità
eppure c'è un'altra azione preventiva da
fare la conosciamo dalla medicina la
prevenzione non arrivare allo spreco e
quello che ci dice l'europa oltre
l'economia circolare il miglior rifiuto
e quindi migliore spreco e quello che
non produci e quello che non fai e per
fare prevenzione abbiamo bisogno di un
aggettivo del cibo che abbiamo perso in
questa polarizzazione in questa
dicotomia dove siamo
grassi e magri dove siamo bulimici e
anoressici dove spa del chiamo da tutte
le parti nel in tv avete in mente tutti
gli chef che sfrigolano che sfilano che
spadellano da tutte le parti non facendo
cosa quello che ci serve per la
prevenzione dello spreco e di tanto
altro ridare valore al cibo e cioè
l'educazione alimentare e questo il cibo
che nella visione azione cibo spreco
zero deve essere educato educare cosa
vuol dire tirare fuori per mettere
dentro qualcosa di buono
ridando valore al cibo ed ecco allora
che quello scarto quel rifiuto in quel
processo di disintegrazione che la
nostra società che si può identificare
con il rifiuto dell'altro
dobbiamo tornare a scuola ed è questa la
sfida e io oso proporvela con coraggio
perché se siamo in più
forse otterremo un risultato dobbiamo
rimettere l'educazione alimentare nelle
nostre scuole
mi viene da dire di ogni ordine e grado
come fossero dei capitoli l'educazione
alimentare della nostra educazione
civica o come si dice oggi alla
cittadinanza a ripartire dal cibo
ridargli valore considerato un diritto
un diritto garantito se non mangi non
vivi rispettando l'identità l'origine e
come sono composte oggi le nostre classi
sono composte da del diciamo da delle
derivazioni del multi multietniche
multireligiose muti paese
e allora attraverso il cibo riscoprendo
il suo valore e rispettandolo nelle
culture diverse che si può fare
integrazione e utopia è una visione sul
futuro che si potrebbe realizzare
io non lo so ma so che la scuola
l'educazione alimentare
so che il riconsiderare il cibo come un
valore e il nostro presente
certo gli studenti i ragazzi gli a nulvi
alunni guardano oltre in una visione di
sostenibilità che poi un patto fa fra
generazioni ma noi dobbiamo ottenere dei
risultati subito altrimenti il mondo va
troppo avanti e tornare indietro non
sarà più possibile allora è da qui che
dobbiamo ripartire e dobbiamo chiederlo
dobbiamo osare perché nessuno ci
risponde nessuno lo fa tutti parlano
parlano parlano cibo cibo cibo e poi
rimane tutto lì nel bidone della
spazzatura e cos'è un utopia per
arrivare diciamo a una visione che ci
può coinvolgere tutti beh io la vedo
come quella straordinaria frase che
scrisse un tempo eduardo galeano che
forse qualcuno di voi avrà letto e un
orizzonte
intanto lo devi lo devi vedere e io l'ho
declino
in tre parole cibo spreco
ma la rivoluzione culturale e è un
attimo basta poco vedere questo
orizzonte perché se ci pensate
la stessa cultura cambiando una vocale
diventa cultura l'alimento diventa
elemento il corrotto diventa corretto e
questa la rivoluzione che io voglio e la
vedo lì non è tanto distante quanti
passi devo fare 100 e incomincia a
camminare e faccio cento passi come sono
arrivato quell'orizzonte lo vedo lo
sento si sposta ancora altri cento passi
e io li faccio e continuo ad andare in
quella direzione
a cambiare le vocali le consonanti a
vedere come fare ma dipende da me e
intanto cammino e si sposta di altri
dieci passi forse diciamo è un po più
vicina
intanto cosa è successo beh io sto
camminando camminate con me grazie